Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Pose estimation is an interesting area of
research where we typically have a few images
or video footage of humans, and we try to
automatically extract the pose a person was
taking.
In short, the input is one or more photo,
and the output is typically a skeleton of
the person.
So what is this good for?
A lot of things.
For instance, we can use these skeletons to
cheaply transfer the gestures of a human onto
a virtual character, fall detection for the
elderly, analyzing the motion of athletes,
and many many others.
This work showcases a neural network that
measures how the wifi radio signals bounce
around in the room and reflect off of the
human body, and from these murky waves, it
estimates where we are.
Not only that, but it also accurate enough
to tell us our pose.
As you see here, as the wifi signal also traverses
in the dark, this pose estimation works really
well in poor lighting conditions.
That is a remarkable feat.
But now, hold on to your papers, because that's
nothing compared to what you are about to
see now.
Have a look here.
We know that wifi signals go through walls.
So perhaps, this means that...that can't be
true, right?
It tracks the pose of this human as he enters
the room, and now, as he disappears, look,
the algorithm still knows where he is.
That's right!
This means that it can also detect our pose
through walls!
What kind of wizardry is that?
Now, note that this technique doesn't look
at the video feed we are now looking at.
It is there for us for visual reference.
It is also quite remarkable that the signal
being sent out is a thousand times weaker
than an actual wifi signal, and it also can
detect multiple humans.
This is not much of a problem with color images,
because we can clearly see everyone in an
image, but the radio signals are more difficult
to read when they reflect off of multiple
bodies in the scene.
The whole technique work through using a teacher-student
network structure.
The teacher is a standard pose estimation
neural network that looks at a color image
and predicts the pose of the humans therein.
So far, so good, nothing new here.
However, there is a student network that looks
at the correct decisions of the teacher, but
has the radio signal as an input instead.
As a result, it will learn what the different
radio signal distributions mean and how they
relate to human positions and poses.
As the name says, the teacher shows the student
neural network the correct results, and the
student learns how to produce them from radio
signals instead of images.
If anyone said that they were working on this
problem ten years ago, they would have likely
ended up in an asylum.
Today, it's reality.
What a time to be alive!
Also, if you enjoyed this episode, please
consider supporting the show at Patreon.com/twominutepapers.
You can pick up really cool perks like getting
your name shown as a key supporter in the
video description and more.
Because of your support, we are able to create
all of these videos smooth and creamy, in
4k resolution and 60 frames per second and
with closed captions.
And, we are currently saving up for a new
video editing rig to make better videos for
you.
We also support one-time payments through
PayPal and the usual cryptocurrencies.
More details about all of these are available
in the video description, and as always.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!